la situation sanitaire en france ses
conséquences on en parle tout de suite
avec l invité politique de la matinale
ce matin fabien roussel secrétaire
national du pcf et avec fabien roussel
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france alors
ces dernières heures les réactions se
multiplient sur les réseaux sociaux
autour d'un nouveau projet de loi en
préparation par le gouvernement décrit
comme la transcription de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire dans le droit commun
je vous propose de re et axes de
regarder ses réactions et puis on en
parle après la loi déposée ce soir par
castex permettrait de vous interdire si
pas vaccinés qu'ovide de vous déplacer
d'accéder à des moyens de transport
d'accéder à certains lieux d'exercer
certaines activités
c'est clairement dictatorial est
totalitaire comme c'était prévisible
emmanuel macron transcrit dans le droit
commun l'état d'urgence sanitaire
un état d'exception sans rapport avec la
démocratie et ce après l'état d'urgence
anti terroriste
la dérive libérale du chef de l'état se
poursuit obligation de se faire vacciner
si on veut pouvoir bénéficier de ses
libertés
eh bien nous y sommes demain voilà donc
des personnalités de différents bords
politiques est ce que vous la
perspective d'un vaccin obligatoire pour
accéder à des droits fondamentaux comme
la mobilité bien à ce que ça vous
inquiète
ce qui m'inquiète d'abord c'est le
manque de confiance de nos concitoyens
dans les vaccins et qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui près plus d'un français
sur deux hésite à se faire vacciner ou
n'entend pas se faire vacciner c'est
d'abord ça qui doit nous inquiéter
il ya besoin de transparence de
confiance dans le vaccin les vaccins ont
sauvé sauf tous les ans des millions de
vies humaines et notamment chez les
enfants on a réussi à éradiquer
certaines maladies et donc pour lutter
contre ce virus il faudra bien se faire
vacciner
or il existe aujourd'hui une grande
opacité
c'est la culture du secret qui entoure
ce vaccin est donc
nous demandons nous beaucoup plus de
transparence sur les contrats qui ont
été placées négocié entre la commission
européenne et les grands laboratoires
pharmaceutiques commencent les tic
d'ailleurs que entre le vaccin le moins
cher et le plus cher il ya huit fois le
prix le moins cher coûte 1 euro 14 et le
plus cher qu'outre et 14 euros
pour quelles raisons il y en a qui est
moins efficace que l'autre vous voyez
moi je suis plus soucieux de partager la
connaissance sur ces vaccins d'être
totalement transparent sur leur
efficacité et leurs limites et de le de
pouvoir les mettre à disposition des
peuples à prix coûtant et j'ai
d'ailleurs vu que dans l'étude de pfizer
il était indiqué que même si on est
vaccinés nous n'avions pas de garantie
que la personne vaccinée puisse ne pas
transmettre le virus et donc il
recommande le maintien des gestes
barrières
il recommande le maintien du port du
masque même si on est vaccinés alors ce
passeport d'immunité ça va faire un film
donc ça vous inquiète pas plus que cela
ce nouveau projet de loi en préparation
par le gouvernement je pense qu'il
risque d'être démontées par la réalité
de ce que les scientifiques et les
médecins vont dire sur les vaccins si
les vaccins ne vous oblige à quand même
porter les masques et à maintenir les
gestes barrière ça veut dire que les
vaccins peut-être nous protégerons mais
pourront quand même transmettre le virus
donc vous voyez bien que ce texte de loi
qui autoriserait aux gens de circuler si
on s'est fait vacciner
ça ne tiendra pas la route une seconde
donc l'attend le temps du débat qui on
verra bien je vous propose de regarder
la réaction de jean castex après
l'annonce finalement de la mise sur le
marché du vaccin biotech pfizer on
regarde on réagit la vaccination
débutera dans les 27 pays de l'union
européenne les 27 28 et 29 décembre à
tous les sceptiques à tous ceux qui en
doutaient l'europe a montré qu'elle
était bien plus qu'un grand marché une
communauté de destin c'est sa
singularité et c'est notre force face à
la crise alors pour le premier ministre
cette vaccination montrent que l'europe
est bien plus qu'un grand marché c'est
une communauté de destin ce que vous
rejoignez ces propos alors d'abord moi
je vais être bien clair sur le vaccin
il faut se faire vacciner je les dis je
le répète c'est une bonne chose que
l'union européenne se soit qu'en
pareilles du sujet et donc et crée les
conditions de pouvoir acheter des
vaccins et les mettre à disposition des
pays de l'union européenne mais par
contre c'est une vaste fumisterie que de
dire que c'est pour le bien commun pour
un destin commun parce que l'union
européenne va d'abord gonfler les
profits des grands laboratoires
pharmaceutiques
c'est ça la réalité et c'est ce qui nous
dégoûte nous au parti communiste
français c'est que des grands
laboratoires vont se faire des profits
sur le dos de cette pandémie
c'est honteux c'est grand laboratoire
pharmaceutique aurait dû créer les
conditions de mettre ce vaccin à
disposition de l'union européenne et des
peuples à prix coûtant et pas se faire
du beurre sur la maladie enfin c'est
quand même honteux que l'ailé légal ne
pense qu'à une chose des actionnaires ne
pense qu'à une chose c'est de gagner de
l'argent être le premier le mettre sur
le marché pour être celui qui va en
vendre le plus mais d'un prix coûtera
néanmoins serment avant certains
laboratoires vont le vendre à prix
coûtant vont pas faire de marge en tout
cas ils ont communiqué dans ce sens ils
ont communiqué comme dans le sens mais
on ne sait rien des contrats qui ont été
conclus rien du tout c'est le secret
l'opacité la plus complète ces accords
ces accords ont été négociés par la
commission européenne
nous n'y avons pas accès - député député
de la nation membre de la commission des
finances à qui on explique tous les
jours qu'il faut faire des économies
qu'il faut faire attention aux deniers
publics
et c'est vrai eh bien je n'ai pas accès
au zoo aux contrats qui ont été
négociées avec ces laboratoires
ça va coûter un milliard cinq à la
sécurité sociale les français vont pas
payer c'est la sécu qui paye mais la
sécu c'est nous qui la finance ont avec
nos cotisations vos cotisations celle
des employeurs et donc nous ce nous
sommes exigeants
sur les dépenses de la sécurité sociale
c'est un milliard cinq
combien va servir à verser des
dividendes aux actionnaires de pfizer
d'astrazeneca de moderna et compagnie
sanofi va verser 4 milliards d'euros de
dividendes à ses actionnaires
vous croyez que c'est juste vous ne
pensez pas qu'on devrait avoir justement
un pôle public du médicament en europe
et en france pour garantir l'accès au
vaccin à tous à prix coûtant et en
partageant les brevets et les
connaissances c'est ce que nous devons
pas vers une pétition une pétition que
nous avons lancés dans 13 pays de
l'union européenne un million de
signatures pour exiger de la commission
qu'elle soit totalement transparente sur
les contrats négociés avec les grands
laboratoires pharmaceutiques fabien
roussel il nous reste quelques secondes
néanmoins je souhaitais vous entendre ce
que vous êtes également élue à la
culture à la ville de
saint-amand-les-eaux le secteur de la
culture on le sait très impacté par la
crise le conseil d'état examiné neuf
recours des professionnels de spectacle
une décision sera rendue mercredi soir
qu'est ce que vous en attendez vous
j'attends que le conseil d'état
remettent en cause la décision du
gouvernement qui a décidé de maintenir
fermer les lieux de culture alors que de
l'autre côté il a décidé de laisser
ouvert les lieux de culte à quelle
différence il y à en être après mois le
virus dans une église dans une mosquée
dans une synagogue que dans un théâtre
que dans un cinéma et quelle incohérence
avec les grandes surfaces qui sont
ouvertes et devant lesquelles sa masse
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
pour aller faire les courses dans la
frénésie des fêtes de noël la seule
chose que propose ce gouvernement aux
familles à l'occasion des fêtes comme
loisir c'est faites vos courses
c'est honteux quand même on veut
justement on a besoin dans notre pays
deux cultures la france est un pays de
culture la culture c'est la france eh
bien nous avons besoin d'eux aussi de
s'oxygéner de s'évader dans un théâtre
dans un cinéma dans un lieu de spectacle
avec ses enfants
et dans ces lieux là nous sommes
protégés parce que nous avons un masque
il ya un siège sur deux occupés fin bref
toutes les conditions
peuvent être réunies pour avoir accès
aux lieux de culture merci beaucoup
fabien roussel d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes député pcf du nord
secrétaire national du pcf